I have to kind of apologize I thought
about how to do this right I could have
done this with actual how the IRSA
system would actually work with actual
numbers with an actual like long message
and all that kind of thing and we could
do with computers I could show you how
to do it and I thought no no I actually
want you to see the maps of what's going
on so I have picked simple simple things
like a one letter message okay so
forgive me for that
I should okay yeah so so now let me
start so the RSA cryptosystem right RSA
stands for these three names on Rivest
that's a V Rivest Shamir Adelman these
guys were geniuses okay and you'll see
why as you as the method unfold but no
one no one remembers their names so we
just call it RSA okay the RSA
cryptosystem it works like so what you
need is an encryption pair of numbers
okay and this is kind of like the pair
of locks that's sorry not the pair of
lock the pair of numbers is the lock
that I hand out to everyone okay so I
this pair of numbers okay and I say look
you want to send me you want to send me
any message you like okay use this this
lock right to lock up your message and
then I'll be able to decipher it and
only I will be able to separate so just
as an example suppose you want to very
secretive you want to send you the
letter B okay so go home my boat all
right so how do we do this let me show
you then that Saab is deceptively simple
but you do need to remember a little bit
about what we did with modular
arithmetic on the Caesar cipher I
promised our dear heart okay so here's
what we're going to do first there this
is this is text but we need to deal with
numbers right so I'll convert this to a
number okay
so numerically like we can decide
whatever but I suppose we'll call it -
what are we okay so - that's the actual
definite text for number we're going to
send okay now I want to I want to use
the cipher on this thing okay so I'm
going to do is I'm going to take this
number - okay I'm going to raise it to
the first power the power of the first
number as you said right so to the power
of five and then I'm going to say more
the second number
this is what I'm going to calculate this
is how I'm using the numbers so first if
you set the letter C which would be 3
then what you would calculate is 3 to
the power of five more 14 okay let's
just quickly do this because the numbers
are okay that's how I chose them right
to the power of 5 to 2 notice that's 32
good right mod 14 now do you remember
what mod means no sugar is knitted right
this number 14 is called the modulus
what I want is the remainder that I get
that's left after I divide 32 by 14 okay
so of course the biggest number the
biggest multiple the 14 you can fit into
this is 28 and so what's left over is 4
does that make sense yeah so that's a 4
mod 14 okay so now for this is my
ciphertext okay so the ciphertext my
encrypted message okay will be 4 which
is D I guess ok so that's what you send
to me right and now it's a secret the
original message is lost how do i
decipher this okay well you don't use
this pair of numbers okay I have the R
value of the key right the key is
related to this the second number the 14
is the same but for decryption the first
number is different right so in some
sense is this first number
it's the secret it's the it's the key if
you find it out you can decipher
everything that comes to me okay so in
this case the decryption key is 11 14
like I said this number here the modulus
is the same but this number here this
one is the key now what do I do with
this well I'm going to go through the
same process but I'm going to use this
pair of numbers instead of this pair of
numbers okay I take your ciphertext
right which was the ladder deep and I'm
going to go through this whole person
again
I have to convert it to a number which
is 4 ok then I raise it to this power
and I say more 14 okay now to the power
of 5 you could do that in your head
before the power of 11 maybe not so get
your calculator out
yes well how do you get eleven I'll get
to that but the point is I know what it
is and you don't talk that's part of the
point that you can't just you can't just
see oh yeah five means eleven right the
point is that no one can work it out
in fact it's I'll show I'll tell you how
hard is to a gap in the end so I have
this can yep
no no and you also think what if it was
always going to be 11 it'll be a pretty
lousy education All Right see you guys
later there now yeah so the first thing
you do the first thing you do is for the
power of 11 okay for to the power of 11
okay now then you get out this monstrous
number okay and this is mod 14 okay mod
14 so unfortunately or maybe fortunately
um our calculators don't have a mod
button on there okay so I will short
show you a sort of a quick and dirty
shortcut that will work out what this
number is and actually part of your
homework I'm going to make a star here
so I don't forget it part of your
homework in a post after this lesson is
to explain what I'm about to do so you
want to take note of what I do fairly
carefully okay why does what I do what
is why is what I will do why does it
work and it introduces there's a problem
with the method it's easy to solve by
what you work out number one why does it
work number two why does it introduce
this problem to strange kind of problem
all right so here's what we going to do
remember this is about remainders right
and division all I kind of think so the
first thing I'll do is I'll take that
number which is on my display and I'll
divide by the modulus 14 so you divide
by 14 and it'll give you like I gives
you a fraction but I want the decimal
okay
so this shows me two nine nine five nine
three point one four two nine blah blah
blah blah blah okay so I see that number
okay now what I want to do is just
mentally take note of the integer part
of that No
which is two nine nine five nine three
okay so what I'm going to do is actually
should put that off on the side but I'm
running in a space swimming what I'm
going to do is I'm going to subtract the
integer part from the whole number okay
so on my calculator with this on the
display I say minus two nine nine five
nine three okay and what's left is a
decimal in fact it's this decimal okay
now once I've got that decimal there I
want to multiply back by this modulars
fourteen okay if I multiply by fourteen
what my calculator then says is no money
cookies my calculator then says this and
there's an eight or a couple of eights
on the end okay now what number is this
close to 2 so this is 2 mod 14 okay let
me just remind you what's going to go in
that hand word person number one why
does this work it's not that that's not
the hard part okay
why does this spit out the correct this
is called the residue what's left over
okay
why does that work and secondly why does
it do this hmm you think about it you
can work it out okay that's that's going
to go into your home if you have a it's
up I know there's an easy way I this is
a particular way that there's being for
all of us suffering
yeah okay all right so yeah yeah why
doesn't he give us two why doesn't it
give it to because the [ __ ] gives to
okay so now how about what just happened
I finished the process the process is
done I started with your cipher texts
you sent me D right and so I went
through this process and at the end I
end up with this which is your original
text B and I have deciphered it it would
and you can go ahead and you can test
out what you need is you need to encrypt
it like this and then decipher it with
this using this interesting combination
of the power and this module of the
relative